businesses started approaching us and
they told us wait
when i'm selling my couch i can accept
payments in in credit cards within
minutes uh
but when i want to accept payments as a
business it takes me three weeks i need
to work with
two different or four different vendors
and it's really complicated can you help
me out
and that's where we took the entire
infrastructure we built
for the second hand website and just
pivoted completely into small businesses
within six months we had more small
businesses joining
our payments uh service than all
the credit card companies in israel
combined
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're going to be talking
about the financial services sector to
micro businesses
meet adam kogan co-founder and head of
product of payment
an israeli fintech company providing
financial services to micro businesses
payment is his third company since
leaving the military as an
officer in the military intelligence
adam cogan welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm great happy to be here thanks for
having me thank you for joining me and
from the payme offices
uh it's an interesting story in the
israeli ecosystem
and the story that i'm excited to be
told and i'm excited to follow
with your or with you on your journey
and understanding a little bit better
why you did what you did and how you
positioned pay me
currently as a is an amazing company
generating
tens of millions of dollars of revenue
but actually just raised
and only 150 000 and bootstrapped and
and a lot of lessons to be learned along
the way and so adam what i'd love to
hear from you in these 20 minutes is
take me through your journey
and you know from the lenses of of you
as the entrepreneur
walk me through some of the experiences
the milestones and what you learned from
them
and i'll of course stop and ask
questions along the way but but please
get started
sure so um in 2014
i was a young officer in the idf in
military intelligence
and i was ready to to conquer the world
uh when i left the army and my commander
in the army
actually introduced me to his best
friend my current co-founder
adam kima and it was
love at first sight uh basically um
i thought i was smart successful
and had a lot of abilities and it turned
out how far i've
how far from the truth that was um
and that that's where the connection was
made uh we just
um wanted to find things we can do
together
he gave me uh the idea for my first
startup
of which was paymates which was
basically very similar to
paybox when purchasing a vacation or a
gift how to
split it between a few friends that was
a complete failure
and from that came pay me so
pay me was another idea the initial idea
of pay me
was to go on uh sites like judge time
win-win craigslist and basically um
add credit card payments when you want
to sell your bike or your couch
instead of it being by check or buy cash
so within three months we didn't know
anything about
anything basically but we convinced the
largest
um credit card company in israel to
launch
a project with us uh so we launched with
israel card
on the win-win website so basically
anyone who wanted to sell
any second-hand item could um
immediately accept payments
so that project um launched very quickly
and it failed very quickly so fourteen
thousand
shekels i think that's like three
thousand dollars
uh within two weeks about two thousand
of that was fraud
um so that was the hello and welcome to
payments
uh for us amazing so
so from that point um
the new payment was born when we didn't
know what to do
uh but businesses started approaching us
and they told us wait when i'm selling
my couch i
can accept payments in in credit cards
within minutes uh
but when i want to accept payments as a
business it takes me
three weeks i need to work with two
different or four different vendors
and it's really complicated can you help
me out
and that's where we took the entire
infrastructure we built for the
second hand website and just pivoted
completely into small businesses within
six months we had more small businesses
joining
our payments uh service then all
the credit card companies in israel
combined
so from uh being
very very um bad at something we we did
okay
wow incredible and so walk me through
you know
growing as payment your decision to
bootstrap what you've learned along the
way
and and what are some of the the
interesting insights you learned about
you know growing a startup within israel
that might not be so trivial
yeah so our journey was i think
unconventional for a startup
um i think well what we did
was we were very very focused on a
specific segment which was
and is small businesses those zero to
four
employees uh that is they're basically
92 percent of
all the businesses they're 50 of the gdp
and they're probably the most overlooked
uh an
underserved segment of the entire
economy
um what we did is we focused on solving
their problems
we started off in payments then we
transitioned
and expanded into financing we expanded
then
um more to invoicing
uh value-added services really solving
the entire ecosystem for that small
business
what's um i think unique about our our
business model is
we don't sell to businesses directly uh
we sell to organizations that sell to
businesses
so for example we um partner with
israel card with wix with zap with
icount
uh basically crms invoicing companies
uh website builders uh organizations
that work with small businesses
and using our platform they can
incorporate financial services
into their offer so wix for example
instead of just giving you a website
uh can give you a payment solution an
invoicing solution a financing solution
all under the wix umbrella so they get a
much better value proposition
they generate more revenue from each of
their
merchants and obviously it's better for
the merchants since
they have everything all in one place so
that was really our story we started off
in the israeli market
and each year we said okay we're just
uh going to get to this milestone and
then we're going to expand globally
but since we decided to also pause and
reflect on this idea to bootstrap
because you know when we're looking at
the at
the ecosystem today and obviously we're
talking about a different time but
but you know the ecosystem is centered
around you know this idea of venture
capital
funded companies that are you know with
the immense competition the companies
have to raise
capital early on so that they have you
know a lot of runway and can grow
exponentially
you decide to go a different routing to
bootstrap it with only a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
in uh you know in in venture capital
investment or
an investment in general where today the
average seed company i believe raises
anywhere from three to seven million
dollars
right yeah so you're absolutely right uh
we definitely chose the road less
traveled
um i think um
one of the main initiatives behind that
was we saw a lot of our friends that
raised funds and they raised seed rounds
and a rounds
and basically they gave up control of
their company
so i had one of my friends from the army
that was fired
as ceo from his startup uh we had
other friends that suddenly had a very
demanding board
that actually interfered with the
company's
day-to-day performance and decision
making and
i think it's it's important to to
understand that
investors are not always aligned with
what's best for the company
uh because and it makes sense they have
their own priorities
i think for us we knew we wanted to do
a very large round when we wanted to
expand globally
so we chose not to do the smaller seed
rounds and a rounds and b
rounds uh and instead we said
we have the ability to actually raise
money
on our terms and we're willing to pay
the price we're willing to progress
slower uh we're willing to finance the
progress of the company from revenue
um time will tell which strategy is best
we every year we we still think um
what's the right decision for us i know
we're gonna raise
a substantial amount uh a substantial
financing round
uh in the next uh six months to a year
wow and so you know what i
st dwelling on this a little bit wha
what does this allow you or force you to
because on one hand it sounds to me like
that just the simple sentence of saying
we're we're operating based off of our
revenues
it sounds to me like there is
implications on focus there's
implications on
the on the need to find a product market
fit but one that actually generates
money at the end of it and not just one
that looks good on on a on a powerpoint
deck what what are some lessons that he
learned through this
bootstrapping behavior um so as a
bootstrap
company uh there are very unique
challenges
um you don't have you don't get the
opportunity to make
bad judgment calls you you need to be
very very precise
you can't experiment uh so
you can have ten options uh to expand it
from
you need to select two and then go with
that one
you don't have the funds to bring in
the best uh most talented people
uh that are former vice presidents at
google
and facebook you have to hire for
potential uh
very very unique circumstances for a
bootstrap company and
your decision making does not
uh optimize or grow it actually
optimizes
for generating enough revenue to making
payroll
generating enough revenue so you can
grow in another
one two three four team members uh
it is very satisfying
um but really the difference between a
standard business
and a startup is basically the
the potential for scale i have yet to
find
it to found to find a way for us to to
scale
without a significant investment of
funds
but the question is at what point um
so if you do that large financing round
uh in the beginning
you are giving up a lot of equity you
are giving up a lot of control
and that's not on your terms if you're
doing that
financing round at a later point i can
tell you um
from experiences right now that's
pretty much um offers
that are much more catered to your needs
and your desires
and you're in a much better position to
to be in control of the financing round
uh when you're raising to grow and not
raising to survive
right what so as you were going along
the way what what challenges did you
have by not raising capital that as a
bootstrap company said ah
maybe i should have just raised those
three million dollars see like all of my
friends
and i didn't and i wouldn't have to
worry about all this stuff
so probably the most basic ones um
you can't lose customers at all
because they're they're paying for next
month's salary
uh so you a lot of times when a customer
has a specific demand and they need a
specific development
you have to do that otherwise you're
going to lose that that customer
so it's a challenge i won't lie i think
the upsides are very very clear
another example is as i said
when you bring in a new employee
you have to compensate them um
in a way that you keep in a way that
a company that would raise a lot of
money
they would have probably offered a very
high compensation
from a salary perspective
yeah exactly so you need to find other
ways to compensate them
so whether they're connected to your
mission or they get stock options
uh which is another option um
i think one of the biggest challenges
and i
i'm probably not surprising anyone
is raising and and getting talent
to join your company companies that
raise
hundreds of millions or tens of millions
of uh
dollars get exposure they get that brand
recognition
and talented people want to work for a
company that's first of all
successful global uh growing rapidly
and if you're none of those things um
but you have a lot of potential
it's a hard selling point right um so i
think
um recruiting talented people has
always been a challenge um one of the
the reasons that we're putting in uh
more effort right now into building
uh brand recognition is so we can
recruit
uh the very best that makes a lot of
sense now tell me a little bit about
you know what you mentioned before we
started recording that one of the big
lessons that you learned is about the
israeli market and
you know as an israeli company you're
obviously you know you're the first
sales happened in israel but then yeah
you have to decide at some point when to
expand
outside of the israeli market and you
mentioned that that point and decision
is not that trivial and one that maybe
looking back you would have done a
little bit differently
tell me tell me your the lessons you
learned from that
so getting back to the implications of
being a bootstrapped company
um after about three years in the
israeli market
we started having let's say overtures
into europe
so we started talking with european
banks with european potential partners
um and the problem was it was basically
me getting on a flight and having some
meetings with them
later that day i had to go on my
computer and actually work with
the next sprint for our israeli partners
now
that doesn't work uh when you need to
expand
to a new region you need to put in the
work you need to
learn the especially in our case with
the
being in the financial industry you need
to know the local regulation
uh you need to understand the local
market needs
it's not one person getting on a plane
and hoping for the best
expanding internationally takes
a lot of resources uh you need to bring
in
local people that are familiar with the
market
so every time we try to expand globally
without putting in the required
resources uh
it didn't pan out um that's where we
really
um came to the realization that if you
want to expand
you need to go um the way that's
already proven um bring in the required
resources
and have money to burn actually because
expanding into a new market is a lot of
trial and error
a lot of error and
you need to have that runway in order
for you to be successful or give you a
chance
give yourself the chance to be
successful so you know tying the knot
and closing the
circle on the idea of bootstrapping
which is at the end you know
that's a really impressive thing to do
especially today
it's very tempting to just go and raise
money in a world that you know is filled
with venture capital investors that are
hungry for these success stories
and so it you know talking to a young
entrepreneur that is now building a
startup and he's not even thinking about
bootstrapping
what are some key considerations that
you would suggest that
i or my friends take into account so
that we at least consider this option
which today
i'm pretty sure that i'm right that
people just dismiss it from the from the
get-go
definitely um i think people from
especially fresh out of the idf from
technological units
uh they read the papers and they see
company a raise the hundred million
company b
rates 300 million and they're saying to
themselves
well why not me um
well one consideration is
when you see these companies that
eventually
ipo uh or or are sold
for billions and billions of dollars how
much
is left to the actual entrepreneur
uh because we had a few ipos uh lately
and you see that the venture funds that
actually invested
that venture fund made 100 million 300
million 400 million
the actual on entrepreneurs and their
share
is quite small so i think
building an amazing company and putting
in
8 10 15 years of your life
needs to be worthwhile um
that's an important consideration for us
also an entrepreneur that raised money
uh and sold his company for a billion
dollars or two billion dollars
who probably at the at the end get the
same amount
as an entrepreneur that didn't raise
money and sold his company
for 100 million now that's an important
question to
to ask yourself what are you in this
court
um and i
i would definitely advise every young
entrepreneur
one decide what you want to do
and decide how much the next 10 to 15
years of your life are worth to you
um when you bring in investors
it is no longer your company it is a
shared company
and in a lot of cases you don't get the
last
save um if you're gonna raise money
i would wait until it is on your terms
and it is a more balanced relationship
um if you don't have to raise
obviously that's that's a situation we'd
all like
thank you for coming and sharing your
insight this story of payment i
believe is just beginning and you're
mentioning that you're putting a lot
more focus on the brand and and
will be entertaining a financial round
on your terms this time
and and i think that that's a very
important lesson to be learned an
important story to be told so thank you
for coming and sharing with me
i want to take you back to your
childhood what fascinated you as a kid i
have three
short and fun questions the first one is
what fascinated you as a kid
so uh entrepreneurs oh always
entrepreneurs
i would look at documentaries on the
history channel
where you have jp morgan uh you have
andrew carnegie
all those titans of industry that
builds empires and as as someone that
grew up
uh without a lot of money it was
baffling to me
how people can accumulate billions and
billions of dollars
in one lifetime
today so today where do you where do you
derive your inspiration today
uh i think um books
probably um there is so much knowledge
out there
um that you know we as people gathered
and i think we don't take enough
advantage of of reading
you know from podcasts obviously that
bring in super smart talented people
uh from all over the uh the
globe which you can learn from you can
learn
from their mistakes you can learn from
their successes
you can read it in books you can uh
watch a documentary you have access to
all of mankind's knowledge
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself i would say
hungry uh relentless and goal oriented
hungry relentless and goal-oriented adam
thank you very very much to nagaba
this was great best of luck with payment
i can't wait i can't wait to see
you know where this is headed and
ultimately see how the strategy plays
out
and i think it's an important strategy
strategy to be thinking through
especially in a crazy time like this
with with all the money going around so
thank you for coming and sharing your
story with me
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
you